ينضم الينا ايضا من هاتاي مراسل الجزيره
يونس ايه ياسين الذي يتواجد في مدينه
انطاكيا التابعه لولايه هاتاي وهي الولايه
التي
تعتبر من اكثر الولايات العشر المتضرره
مئات المباني سويت بالارض سنحاول ان نفهم
اكثر المشهد ونبدا مع يونس ايه ياسين طبعا
هاتاي كما علمنا الرئيس التركي تحدث عنها
بالخصوص لانها بحاجه الى مساعدات كثيره
ضمن التعبئه العامه التي اعلن عنها اليك
الكلمه يونس
نعم بالفعل عبد السلام هتى ربما احصائيه
فقير احصائيه واحده تلقي الضوء على حجم
الدمار الذي شهدته هذه الولايه وهذه
المدينه تحديدا بحكم انطاكيا يعني هي اكبر
المدن في هذه الولايه بها ربع سكان هذه
الولايه الاحصائيه هي ان نصف عدد البيوت
التي دمرها هذا الزلزال وهذا الزلزالان
توجد في ولايه هاتاي وهذا مؤشر كافي اكدته
المشاهده العينيه التي شاهدناها بالامس
كنا في غازي عنتاب يعني تتجول احيانا
كيلومترات في غازي عنتاب لتجد مبنى مدمرا
بشكل كامل الان هنا في مشارف مدينه
انطاكيا اينما وليت وجهك تجد مبنى مدمرا
هذا المبنى الذي يوجد خلفي كان فيه 27
شخصا اثناء الزلزال
الحمد لله يعني انه كلهم سالمين باستثناء
شخص واحد فقط توفي وخلف دمارا كبيرا على
الجهه الاخرى من الشارع يوجد مبنى اخر
مدمر بشكل تقريبا بشكل كامل الان الجرافات
تقوم بعمليات الحفر من اجل الوصول الى
ناجين محتملين وان كان الحقيقه بعد مضيف
ثمانين ساعه خصوصا اذا اخذ بعين اعتبار
الطقس القاسي الذي عاشته المدينه خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه اليوم درجه
الحراره مرتفعه نسبيا لكن خلال يعني اليوم
الاول بعد زلزال واليوم الثاني درجه
الحراره انخفضت الى مستويات بارده جدا
وكان هناك تساقط هائل للثلوج تساقط
للامطار بالاضافه الى تاخر وصول الجرافات
وصول عمال الانقاذ هذه الجرافات التي
تراها الان في الشاشه عبد السلام وصلت قبل
24 ساعه فقط لانه بعد مضي حوالي 50 ساعه
بدات عمليات الانقاذ هذا ربما ما يخفف من
توقعات بالوصول الى اي ناجين على المبنى
على الجهه اليمنى مثلا تضرره ايضا بشكل
كامل وليس بشكل كامل لكن بشكل جزئي عفوا
تم اخرائه بشكل كامل على الجهه اليسرى
هناك فندق لهذا المبنى الذي توجد فيه
الجرافات على الجهه اليسرى اذا يعني يحرك
المصور الكاميرا الى الجهه اليسرى على
الفندق
احد اجنحه هذا الفندق سقط على يعني
عماره سكنيه اخرى وهناك حديث عن ان على
العشرات من الاشخاص يوجدون تحت هذه تحت
هذا الركام وحتى الان لم يتم الوصول اليهم
بالتالي الصوره هنا في يعني انطاكيا وهطاي
عموما تعطي صوره قادمه عن اضرار هذا
الزلزال ولم تتكشف بعد حقيقه اثار هذا
الزلزال يعني وما الذي خلفه من ضحايا هناك
توقعات بان عدد القتلى سوف يعني يرتفع
بشكل كبير بمجرد تقدم عمليات البحث
وعمليات الانقاذ اريد فقط ان اذكر تفصيل
عبد السلام
الرحله من غازي عنتاب التي قدمنا منها
صباح اليوم الى هطاي تستغرق ساعتين ونصف
اليوم استغرقت من الرحله حوالي خمس ساعات
لان الطريق اولا يعني متشققه وهناك حظر في
السياقه
والاضافه الى الازدحام الكبير بالنظر الى
بدء الامدادات شاحنات كبيره تحمل المياه
تحمل الاغذيه تحمل يعني الفرق المتطوعين
التي بدات تلتحق بشكل يعني متواتر الى
الولايه في المساعده في عمليات البحث
شاحنات الوقود بالنظر الى شح هذه المواد
خلال في الولايه والمدينه خلال الفتره
الماضيه سيارات الاسعاف التي تسمعها ربما
والتي لا تتوقف سيارات الاسعاف تدخل
المدينه بشكل مستمر وتخرج منها بشكل مستمر
لاخراج الضحايا او الاشخاص الذين يحتاجون
الى الرعايه الصحيه نحن لم نتجول بعد في
كامل الولايه سوف نقوم
بجوله خلال هذا اليوم لكن ما لمحناه حتى
الان يرسم صوره قادمه وينبئ بان
الحصيله النهائيه سوف تكون مرتفعه جدا في
هذه الولايه عبد السلام